this psychologist named Piaget some of
you might know about him mm-hmm
Piaget was very interested in what
happens to value structures and their
hierarchical organization once they have
to apply outside of the confines of a
body so here's a way of thinking about
it
two-year-olds basically hypothalamic
that's why they're so much fun
first they're happy then they're sad
then they're hungry then they're tired
you know they just zip from one pretty
straightforward and rather awe-inspiring
motivational state to another and but at
two they can't play they can play with
by themselves but they can't play with
other children they can't get that until
they're three and they need to get it by
the time they're free because if they
don't get it by the time they're four
they will never get it and then you have
an antisocial kid who's going to be an
outsider for his entire life and there
isn't anything you can do about it so
that has to happen between two and four
so what happens at about age three is
that the kid learns how to play a game
with another person and what that game
is is fundamentally the development of
the ability to share a frame of
reference which is what you're doing
when you play Monopoly it's like it's
stupid to play Monopoly obviously who
cares if you have a whole pile of
counterfeit paper right but doesn't
matter it because the way you're
constituted is that your brain will
treat anything you act like constitutes
a valuable goal as if it's a valid
framework of reference and if it
couldn't do that a you couldn't abstract
and be you could not get along with
other people so you can sit around the
table and you could say let's pretend
that monopoly is a reasonable facsimile
of reality which you wouldn't say but
it's what you mean and everybody says
yes that would be amusing
and so then you set your goal which is
to get all the little hotels and all the
money and proof your emotions go along
for the ride and what's so interesting
about that is you can get everybody into
the game and so one of the things that's
really interesting about people is that
we can establish a shared fictional
frame of reference and it organizes all
our emotion
so they're predictable that's also why
we can watch movies you go to the movie
you identify the hero you figure out
what the hero wants who you're the hero
and the way that works is you don't look
at the hero and think about what he's
doing and evaluated emotionally and then
feel it what you do is you specify the
hero's goal and then you map him on to
your body and you read off the emotional
responses of your own body
and that's how you understand the hero
so it's it's embodied you're using your
your embodiment as a computational
device that can run simulations of other
consciousness and it does that with the
body and we like doing that you can go
to a movie and you know you're Brad Pitt
for an hour and a half you know when
you're Brad Pitt doing remarkable things
and that's also how we understand other
people we're very good at that so
anyways we have these shared frames of
reference like when we're playing
Monopoly ok so children at free learn
how to play games and that means they
learn how to organize their own internal
motivational States into a hierarchy
that includes the motivational states of
other people and that means they can
play and that's what you guys do when
you're out in the world like we're
playing a game right now we all know the
rules that's why we can all sit in this
room and play the game without fighting
with each other you know when the room
is set up like a theater and we all know
the theater game and so and the chairs
are always facing this way at the moment
and so that's a hints that you should
look forward and this is raised so you
know the room is basically telling you
what to do because it's a stage like all
rooms and because you're smart and
socially conscious you can walk into a
stage through and your body knows what
to do and if you're civilized and social
you just do it then all the other
primates can predict what you're up to
and they won't kill you yeah well that's
what it means to be part of the same
tribe you know when people are very
peculiar creatures and god only knows
what they're up to but as long as
they're playing the same game you are
you don't have to know what they're up
to because you can predict what they're
going to do and you understand their
motivational space and so part of the
building and constructing of higher
order mode of higher order morale
Gold is the establishment of joint
frames of reference that allowed
multiple people to pursue the goals that
they're interested in simultaneously and
then what you have to think about with
regards to that is that not all shared
frames of reference can manage that
there's a small subset of them that are
optimized so that not only can multiple
people play them but multiple people can
play them and enjoy them and do it
repeatedly across a long period of time
so it's iterate ability that partly
defines the utility of a higher order
moral structure and that is not
arbitrary it's an emergent property of
biological interactions and you might
say well it's kind of arbitrary because
people can do what they want but it's
not arbitrary at all because a lot of
what's constraining your games is your
motivational sub structure and those
ancient circuits that are status
oriented and they operate within
virtually every animal has a status
counter creatures organize themselves
into dominant hierarchies the reason
they do that is does that work it's a
solution it's a solution to the
Darwinian problem of existence it's not
just an epiphenomenon it's the real
thing
so you your environment fundamentally a
huge chunk of your environment is
dominant our key plus god only knows
where you are and that's order and chaos
and part of the reason that people fight
to preserve the dominance hierarchies is
because it's better to be a slave who
knows what the hell is going on then
someone who's thrown screaming and naked
into the jungle at night and that's the
difference between order and chaos and
we like order better than chaos and it's
no wonder
now we'll invite a little chaos in for
entertainment now and then it has to be
done voluntarily and generally you don't
want the kind of chaos that upsets your
entire conceptual structure you know
you're willing to fool around on the
fringes a little bit but you know when
the going gets serious you're pretty
much likely to bail out and no wonder